how did you become so resourceful in
building bill incorporated baby needs
shoes what are you gonna do you know
that's what that's why I'm at least for
me the important thing was cut the ties
no day job nothing else do you make it
don't delude yourself if you can't make
it as an actor go work at the Kwik Stop
do something else but don't pretend that
one day I'm going to make it as an actor
make it or don't make it that's my
theory is the only thing that's worked
for me have you always had this sort of
tough love perspective or or matter of
fact in the way of getting yourself out
there and dealing with rejection or did
this come over time through getting
knocked down and having to learn to get
back up I've never known anything else
than being picked eyeliner being felt
odd or being excluded I was never
popular I'm not an attractive guy I've
never felt as if I fit in anywhere but
luckily I picked a professional all of
those things are assets and not
liabilities so yeah I I love being able
to manipulate marketing results I've
always been fascinated by how you can
tell people what a product is and if you
do it correctly they will believe it and
purchase the product I find that
fascinating endlessly so my little
marketing brain is always thinking what
can I do
what can I do
to kind of do new avenues new avenues
take this lollipop came out in Germany
on German television and so I thought I
wonder if I could get some German
producers and distributors interested in
me because it was very popular in
Germany and so I sent them a link from
YouTube of a German site called Der
Spiegel TV and they were talking in
German about also she loved it bought a
vehicle but Julia so I wrote my little
cover letter in German using Google
Google Translate and wrote to about 13
distributors and I got a nice bite from
a pretty big German distributor of
horror movies and they want to talk to
me about doing a development deal based
on you know the strength of to take this
lollipop thing not the same character
but doing some horror movies with me and
that was just because I thought how can
I make this work for me and exploit this
it was all free it cost nothing how do
you manipulate Google search and and
what does that mean to go wide like what
what exactly are you doing like that you
can manipulate Google search results by
having multiple instances of whatever
surgery zone you want across the web you
want to have the same message in the
same keywords in in metadata if possible
within the website in your own website
certainly but across the every interview
that you do every piece of PR you put
out have those same keywords that you
want associate it with it Google image
search results are very easy in a minute
but you need to have the right pixel
size at least 500 pixels wide you need
to have an alt within there if there's
an alt tag 500 pixels wide if you can
put the name on the picture that's even
better but you don't have to it's going
to pick it up the spiders gonna look for
the alt tech first the size second and
then multiple instances of that image
across the web it's been this is what
you sit there in your pajamas for 12
hours and you look up and it's 7 o'clock
and you think my god I didn't even eat
lunch but I manipulated Google search
results which is more important I don't
know I guess it depends what
well and then everyone thinks that
acting is so glamorous and it's walking
the red carpet and doing all the warmer
but this this is what it really is do
you think a lot of people have in them
those things to sit behind that computer
and to do a lot of very boring dull work
with no interaction from other people
except a computerised message back and
forth no I mean I yeah I wish that I had
come to Hollywood before I was born in
the days when you actually could be
discovered but you can't now and this is
what you have to do you have to build
yourself before anybody's going to be
interested in you
and if you don't have the resilience to
do that then you know you don't people
call you from back home and from other
places and they said what are you doing
at work and oh you're on set no in front
of the computer oh you're playing in
front of the computer they have no idea
and you can't describe to them because
they get bored I mean you talk about the
intricacies of HTML text they don't care
but if an actor is not really really
really computer savvy like these two
sides of your brain are mini actors oh
you know I I just want to act
I just want to act maybe you can't act
unless you mark it you've got to do both
so you have your marketing head on and
then when it's time to turn that off
close that file open up your performing
brain and maybe this came from years of
touring theatre where I actually had to
load in props and set up sound and do
sound checks and then realized oh my god
now I actually have to do the show too
and tear it down and drive to the next
town so you can park mentalize things it
helps to be a little nuts well we hear
this from a lot of the actor friends
that we know that oh I I don't want to
do I don't have a YouTube channel I
don't want to deal with all the other
brands you know you judge people yeah
yeah well let my people do that for me I
think they have people good but they're
people I haven't had people this is my
people I'm my people people what are
people if I had people I don't think I
trust them I really don't I want to do
this myself this is my persona my brand
I Know Who I am I don't want people
creating things for me because that's
not authentic it has to be a part of who
I am so what are you doing to drama
work when you go through those stagnant
periods that all actors go to what do
you do to keep that phone ringing you
said work baguettes work or gas work
work as much as you possibly can if
you're not working in a dry spell and we
all hit the dry spells can you work on a
French project do it keep working
because the more you work the more
people see that you're working and they
want to hire you why because you're
working and then you get work because
you're working and it's a complete cycle
don't ever stop working keep creating
opportunities for yourself to work but
in those dry spells you feel like you're
never going to work again and then all
of a sudden the dam burst and usually a
burst because you went ahead and worked
even if you weren't getting paid you did
something you did a favor for a friend
just keep working
you